الى مصر الان حيث قالت اسره الناشط
السياسيه المصريه البريطاني على عبد
الفتاح الذي اضرب عن الطعام والشراب كليا
لعده ايام مطلع الشهر الجاري ان وضعه
الصحيح تدهور بشده خلال الاسبوعين
الاخيرين وكانت والده ونشطه سياسي قد
تمكنت من زيارتها اليوم وفقا لما كتبته
شقيقته منى سيف على موقع ومنصه تويتر
الينا من مصر
والده ناشطه السياسيه على عبد الفتاح
السيده ليلى سويف اهلا وسهلا بك سيد
السويد شكرا على قبول دعوه دعوه
كيف هو على انت همم التقيت به اليوم
تمكنتي من همم معايده
اه تمكن من الزياره وكان الموعد
الطبيعي لزياره الاسراء
ويعني وجدته طبعا في حاله ضعف الشديد
وهو حكى لي انه هو
حصل يعني
اغماءيار همم
الاسبوع همم
الماضي همم
يعني لما حصل الاغماء
محاليل وكده وهو ده يعني عمليه هو ده اللي
كسر ابره وان هو يعني بعد ما همم همم
هذا الاضراب يضربه عن طعام والشراب همم
بالقوه اذا
بالقوه لانه هو كان ااا
يعني
اعتقد السلطات الطبيه
بالضبط كده همم
[موسيقى]
قرر ان هو
يعدد اضاءه بقى بعد العاده الى عيشه وهما
يعني بعض
همم
المعامله اختلفت لان النيابه جاءت له
همم يتم اطلاق سراحه قريبا
يعني انصح بهذا لانه هو يعني احنا احنا
والعالم اللي مهتمه همم
في مصر مش هيسكت وعلي نفسه هو هيعلق اضربه
كم يوم وزلال الامور اتحرك
هيعود الى اضرابه انا اتمنى همم
لصالح
ايضا ال- ال- بعض الهدوء السياسي يعني ولا
الحكمه التعامل مع مع الملفات دي في مصر
انه يتم صراحه قريبا جدا جدا
سويف همم
همم
ابنك يحمل الجنسيه على البريطانيه ماذا عن
تدخل ال- ال- السفاره البريطانيه او
الاطراف البريطانيه لايجاد حل لي على
طبعا
واجب على السلطات البريطانيه
من النتيجه
[موسيقى]
لمعرفه اخر التطورات وحالتها الصحيه هل
يتبع الصحيه
اه اه يعني في اتصالات باينها وفي متابعه
دائما وطبعا بيثيره الامر طول الوقت مع
الاجهزه المعنيه
الحقيقه ان ده مش كفايه لانه على الاقل
يعني اذا ما اتكلمناش حاطه عن الافراد لكن
حاجه زي الزياره القنصليه ما كانش مفروض
تبقى موضوع للجدل اصلا
وهمم خمول همم الموضوع ده هيفضل
يعني يؤجل يؤجل عجل شهور وشهور وشهور
الحقيقه ده يعني
ده شيء فترات نعيم السلطات المصريه لكن
كمان يعيب السلط
انه
ما الذي قاله لك عندما زرتيها اليوم على
ما الذي قال لك يريد مواصله هذا الاضراب
مهما كان
حتى لانه وجد همم يعني اختلاف في المعامله
همم
من قبل همم سلطان السيد ومن قبل همم
المحقق النيابه العامه لجده همم
الاضراب مباشره
همم
لكن انه اذا همم
اذا لم يتحرك همم يعني همم
برده همم
يعني همم
همم
الزياره القنصليه يا كاتب
زياره النهارده برده كانت في الكابينه
الزجاجيه همم يا ريت بقى احنا ليه برده
كانت جميله يعني هو يعني قريبا مره اخرى
هل سيسمح لك بزيارته مره اخرى
سيد ليلي
لكن بصراحه
شكرا جزيلا لك يا سيده ليلى سويف والده
الناشطه السياسيه المصريه البريطانيه
المسجون على عبد الفتاح شكرا